we've got blood tests we've got nasal
swabs all kinds of ways to detect the
Kuroda virus and now we can add to that
mix poop specifically wastewater there's
a company called bio bot that's
analyzing this wastewater to try to look
for the corona virus and they found that
in a lot of cases the virus is much more
widespread than the more conventional
tests would show so let's head off to
Massachusetts to interview the founders
of bio bot would you two mind
introducing yourselves maybe Mariana
first my name my name is Nisha Gailey
and I am co-founder and president at
biobot analytics your company the two of
you have come up with a pretty unique
way to look at that corona virus maybe
you're talking about about sewage coming
from from different parts of the country
right correct
we can detect the virus in wastewater
because people who are infected shed the
virus in school and it makes its way
into the wastewater infrastructure then
wastewater treatment plants collect
samples and send them to us right now
why what has a pro bono campaign and we
are testing about 10 percent of the u.s.
population on a weekly basis versus
about one percent of the u.s. population
that is being tested through the clinics
and the results that you've already seen
a pretty striking yeah our first results
were gathered from a large metropolitan
region in Massachusetts and on the day
that the samples were collected there
were about 450 confirmed clinical cases
in that community and what we were able
to see via sewage testing is that there
were up to 100
thousand people infected with corona
virus in that catchment area so just
dramatically more than what the regular
test was showing yeah exactly
there's actually a large asymptomatic
population likely or individuals who
have very mild symptoms and so they're
not seeking out testing however they're
captured and represented in sewage data
and so we're seeing them in our tests
and and I know you get a 50 milliliter
sample how how is that representative of
an entire city's population so treatment
plants they can sample the wastewater as
it comes into the treatment plant
constantly till 24 hours - currently and
we get representation from every toilet
flush that went through that community
and then from that aggregate sample they
are taking a small animal and sending
that to us and using that sample we
measured how much virus was present in
the wastewater we need a technique
called qPCR the rates for the genetic
signature of the virus okay
and you would already have this company
up and running to kind of look for other
what other diseases in wastewater
already correct we originally were
working with the opioid epidemic
measuring the concentration of different
types of prescription opioids in
wastewater to create better programs
it's not the most glamorous job maybe
what what dream this field I really grew
up with hardship so I've always been
passionate about creating technologies
that help with equity and bring better
resources to people who need it and the
beauty of looking at wastewater as a
diagnostic is that everybody has a voice
in the sewer you don't need to have the
money to go to the doctor you don't need
to have medical insurance as long as
your house is connected to the
wastewater your information is counted
and we can bring that to create better
programming what's your vision for how
this plays out over the the coming years
yeah our vision is that one day
this technology will be basic
infrastructure for every city and town
worldwide so we will be constantly
screening our populations for new
outbreaks of the nocturnal virus and in
the snacks like week two weeks three
weeks I mean there's just gonna be more
and more data coming out obviously from
the work you're doing all of the
facilities that we're working with
really believe that weekly testing is
very important one of the biggest
questions facing government and decision
makers right now is how and when can we
start to safely open up our cities again
and our economies again and testing at
scale is one of the most critical things
in order to help us get there and we're
not gonna be able to test every single
individual that's just not realistic and
so this type of testing can really be
helpful in making these types of
decisions of scaling back quarantine
style measures or social distancing and
so all of the facilities that we're
working with are sending us weekly
samples we're giving weekly data back to
them and yeah we're excited to see how
that progresses
[Music]
you